alors pourquoi ils ont pris cette
décision a pris cette décision d'abord
il faut dire une chose c'est que être
aux manettes aujourd'hui du gouvernement
dans ce contexte c'est très difficile
mais quand même c'est ridicule assure
qu'on soit favorable ou pas au
gouvernement c'est très compliqué
l'écran d'une décision politique de ce
type sais c'est dur je pense pas qu'on
le prend avec effectivement un plaisir
quand on se lève un matin
la difficulté dans laquelle ils se sont
mis si je peux me permettre monsieur le
député gouvernement auquel vous
appartenez
c'est que comme il n'y a pas d'arguments
scientifiques
il ya un contexte général qu'ont
expliqué sur la gravité si les bars et
les restaurants
on leur explique que la fermeture
réglera le problème ce sont des gens
responsables
bien sûr il sert mauron le restaurant
sans aucune hésitation qu'attend
aujourd'hui vous semblez prendre une
mesure qui n'est pas sain de cherté qui
semble brutal symbolique semble qu'elle
soit scientifiquement prouvé même le
professeur à côté vous dit il ya une
situation qui est difficile mais je suis
pas convaincu que la fermeture des bars
restaurants rebond une solution et moi
je n'ai entendu maintes et maintes fois
encore une fois c'est pas le
gouvernement tant que tels que sur
lequel on donne le sentiment de
critiquer c'est la mesure n'étant par gu
mentir vas elle ne peut pas aller
partager on va laisser aller ne faut pas
y aller c'est vrai qu'on est une façon
extrêmement compliqué mais je regarde
pas vous je crois que tout le monde
autour sur ce plateau l'a parfaitement
compris
il ya un concept de bulles de bulles
social qui fait que si on veut ralentir
globalement le virus il va falloir qu'on
est moins d'interactions les uns avec
les autres et c'est vrai quand on parle
des bars et des cadets des cafés ce soir
mais il faut parler aussi des salles de
sport qui seront aussi fermées les
gymnastes sont au taquet baby gym et
démissionna à fermer
visage extrêmement difficile et je
voudrais juste terminée là dessus vous
avez raison dans tout ce que vous dites
nous devons être là pour vous
accompagner pour continuer je suis
d'accord avec monsieur mennucci qui dit
et on doit prendre notre part l'état
doit prendre sa part pour vous
accompagner je crois en tout cas une
invention il ajouté choses et d'autres
choses
on doit aller plus loin il ya des
discussions avec bruno le maire et vos
différents syndicats ce matin même
qu'ils continuent de savoir comment que
vous aider concrètement les prêts
garantis par l'état
c'est quelque chose qui vous aide
j'entends ce que vous avez dit sur les
banques et j'entends ce que vous dites
sur les banques
évidemment il faut qu'on fasse quelque
chose parce que ça c'est pas normal que
vous soyez prêts bien sûr à oui je
l'entends on avance on avance pas avant
que derrière les dernières choses les
cafés par rapport au transport collectif
d'abord un évidement on enlève le masque
et donc il ya un risque supplémentaire
merci chiffres que j'avais c'était
quatre fois plus de risque sur un dans
un bar vous connaissez d'autres ça vous
coupe la ligne
et deuxième chose oui mais je connais
bien la ligne 13 mais c'est en réussite
le but c'est moi et mais je vous assure
qu'il ya beaucoup de monde et
effectivement on est les uns contre les
autres
2 y est deuxième chose je crois qui est
importante c'est qu'évidemment on ne
veut pas on fait tout pour empêcher un
recond finement à répondre un
confinement d'abord qui est très dur
socialement et qui serait extrêmement
préjudiciable économiquement et donc il
faut concours n'arrivent à concerner
puissent continuer à travailler
il avait alors tout ce que vous dites
mais dit fort nous a confié discutons
ensemble pour voir qu'elle rejoint il ya
évidemment vous avez un maillon
essentiel est qu on a beau gars et moi
dans les urnes 10ème sur le débuté il ya
deux jours deux jours vous avez reçu les
patrons des banques à bercy et à beauvau
et vous leur avez annoncé que vous allez
reconfirmer vous avez demandé aux
banques ça s'écrit veut mais je dis cela
je pensais justement mais on va y aller
envoyez mais vous êtes élu non mais je
suis et moi je suis sélectionné mag ou
oxydés le gouvernement je suis pas gomis
juste un atelier bien que je termine et
donc non mais j'en sais ça veut dire que
globalement vous savez convard confiné
en octobre et je suis pas d'accord avec
vous prévu moi je ne peux alors des mois
cyril j'invite là on serait ok oui
j'ai jamais tué personne le 15 octobre
c'est bon ils pourront venir chez moi
alors j'invite mes juillet huit ou dix
où vous êtes sûr qu'on va rencontrer les
riverains sûr on va rendre cool on va
demander à la sauvette viol dans le
sillon pas que ce soit le cas